مشاهد الدمار والخراب توحي بان الصور من
فيلم سينمائي عن نهايه العالم لكن الحال
يؤكد انه من واقع بوابه اقليم دونيتس
كالصناعي في الجزء الجنوبي من ضخموت
الحديث هنا عن التي تشهد قصفا مدفعيا
مكثفا السيطره على المدينه الواقعه على
مسافه 13 كيلومترا فقط عن دوناتسك
تتيح للجيش الروسي قطع خط امداد القوه
الاوكرانيه في الشرق وسيسمح لموسكو باحكام
قبضتها في جنوب وشرق اوكرانيا وضمان تامين
خطوط امداد اللوجستيه للجيش ومع اشتداد
المعارك السلطات الاوكرانيه بدات في سحب
موظفي البلديه من المدينه الجيش الاوكراني
يحاول التمسك بالمواقع الحاليه وصد
الهجمات الروسيه لحين تزويد تلك الجبهه
بالسلاح
خبراء روس يصفون استراتيجيه كياب وحلفائها
لمحاوله ارهاق واستنزاف روسيا في الجبهه
الشرقيه بالفاشله فالجيش الروسي يسيطر على
اكثر من 60% من مساحه بخموت وتحديدا القسم
الشرقي الشرقي نهر بخموتكي اضافه الى
الاحياء الجنوبيه والشماليه وكل الطرق
الواصله الى بخمو تحت السيطره الروسيه
باستثناء طريق واحد للسماح بخروج الجيش
الاوكراني وفي حال سقطت ضخمه بالكامل
وسيطره موسكو على
فان هذا سيسمح للروس بتنفيذ تقدم عسكري
بوتيره سريعه وعلى مساحات واسعه وسقوط
المدن الكبرى في دونتسك وفق خبراء عسكريين